how to become a millionaire by age 25.
so what is the answer on google so as
you can see there's loads of answers and
videos and blogs
countless tens and tens of pages
probably
by people who are not a millionaire and
did not become a millionaire by age 25.
but let's see what google says the top
of google says can you become a
millionaire at 25 it says if you start
making money at 16 years old
you need to earn 305
dollars per day
to make it to a million by 25. starting
at 18 when you graduate high school
means you would need to earn 391 pounds
per day to make it to a million by 25.
i feel like just absolutely pulling my
hair out so
what firstly what what okay great great
maths
what's the actual advice here is the
advice to leave school at 16 and make
305 pounds a day and to just do that
every day until you're 25 and then
you're a millionaire well that is the
worst advice that i've ever heard about
money or being a millionaire let me tell
you why that is completely and utterly
flawed number one because you're gonna
have to work
every single day
saturdays and sundays with zero holidays
for every day for for however many years
like nine years that is not possible i
don't think anybody can work every
single day with zero holidays and zero
for nine years it's not taking into
account weekends or or any holidays or
times off or sick time so
it's gonna be considerably less than a
million because you're not going to work
every single day second massive floor
observation in this is that's assuming
that you spend
nothing to live
right because if you if you're making
305 pounds a day and you do that every
day for nine years you're not a
millionaire because what are you gonna
have done for the nine years just lift
off of thin air
paid no rent not eaten anything
that's just massively flawed probably
half of that or close is going to go
towards your your food accommodation
and everything and then the third reason
it's completely flawed is what 16 year
old can just go oh okay then and just
start making 305
a day
that with no skills with no
it's just absolute horse poo manure it's
just terrible advice so what advice
would i give as someone who actually did
become a millionaire
from scratch by age 25. i was a
millionaire at age 25 so what advice
would i give to a 16 year old well i did
not work every single day for nine years
and make 305 pounds a day and live off
dinner what i did was i learned about
business
if you want to be a millionaire by 25
you're gonna have to learn about
business you can't start making 305
pounds straight away you need to be
thinking instead of about tomorrow or
next week you need to be thinking about
next year so when you start out in
business rather than trying to work for
305 pounds a day you should be working
probably for free
you should be working for free in
exchange for experience about business
you should be to begin with within the
first year of starting out in your
journey to become a millionaire you
should be training educating yourself
learning about business trading your
time for experience and growing yourself
because you're not going to become a
millionaire unless you have a
millionaire mindset brain and a
millionaire skills so the first thing is
forget saving forget trying to make 305
a day forget working every day and
forget that become valuable that's the
very first thing second thing is once
you become valuable and you've learned a
business is you need to understand how
to
value a business
the fastest way you're going to become a
millionaire is through business
and that could be a property business
property investment is a business but
how's business valued
if you want your business your company
to be worth a million pounds net you
need to understand how it's valued and
here's how business is valued generally
speaking it depends on the business but
they will take your annual profit of
your business
and they will then times that by 10
and if your business is functioning only
with you in it so if you're having to be
involved in your business your business
will be valued at zero
if your business is system without you
if you've created a business that's
giving you passive income then your
business will be they'll take your
annual profit and they'll times that by
five to ten depending on the business
and how systemized it is so in other
words if you've got a business it's
completely systemized and it's making
you a hundred thousand pounds a year
that business might be valued up to a
million pounds next so you've got a
million pound business so if you want to
do that what are you gonna need to do
well you're gonna need to start a
business and you're going to need to
learn how to replace yourself you're
going to need to learn how to systemize
the business here's the fastest way to
systemize a business when you let's say
my business was deal sourcing that's how
i became a millionaire deal sourcing was
packaging deals and selling those deals
onto investors for a fee i was the
broker the middleman making three or
five thousand pounds every time i sold a
deal i was selling around about two to
three deals a week
and then i employed a couple people to
come and run my business i had a manager
i had a finance manager i had an
operations manager over the business and
i stepped back and the business was
running without me so what you need to
do is you need to have a organizational
structure every single job that you do
within your business you need to write
down every job create a training manual
for your business put your name next to
every single job and then slowly start
replacing your name
this this is what you need to learn
about business systemization
finance marketing sales tax this is how
you're going to become a millionaire
adding value working for free and i left
school with no qualifications really out
of three gcses and they weren't great so
i started from nothing and i learned
about business and i learned about
creating value and i learned about real
estate and property and investments and
by the age of 25 i was a millionaire so
forget
working for 300 pounds at 300 a day and
saving up and
that's not the goal that's garbage
advice
learn about business so if you've got
questions for me in terms of business
then comment below and i'll do my best
to answer your questions in future
videos if you want to come and spend a
day with me at the
property millionaire intensive where i'm
actually going to show you how to become
a millionaire through business and
through property then i've got some
tickets available they are free tickets
but they're very limited so book now in
the description also if you want to see
a playlist of lots of people that i've
helped become financially independent
and some of them become millionaires
through property check out the whole
playlist here come to the property
millionaire intensive i'll leave a link
right here and i'll see you guys next
time
[Music]
you